I think the thing what I believe with the thing
that gives me hope is I honestly believe if
people understood what was happening here
they would not accept it and we would get
change if people knew the direction that we as a
society are heading and where we're going to go
70,80,90% of people would vote
against it and the only reason that
we are able to make Society worse and
worse and worse and worse and worse
the way we are doing is because people are
misinformed and not giving good information
for me I just wanted to get you on the
channel basically because I know you've
been watching it from the start and I know
like your mates watching stuff like this
and really I just wanted to get somebody in who
watches it to sort of take the place of the people
who watch it and ask the questions that they might
be wondering things they don't understand things
they would like to hear more of yeah I mean I
dip in and out to be honest with you I'm not
up to date fully on the most recent so I guess
it'll be good to know kind of where you're at
and what today's what you're looking to work on
today yeah yeah so today basically I wanted to
get seem to come over in the evening so we could
film some stuff that was like a bit more chill
basically because sin is going away and then I'm
going away so we're not going to be able to shoot
for the whole of November yeah um and the channels
really growing loads of new people are coming
um and we've been like really like doing
up to speed stuff on what's Happening
but we're not gonna have to do that in
the next month so like I wanted to just
do some stuff that was a bit more educational and
it's a bit more chill to really give the people
who are watching the understanding basically
that they're going to need going forward because
I'm not going to be able to give like on the
button analysis of the news every week but this
is not is there a requirement to do that though
with this whole idea something big happens not
necessary I know that some people watch this
channel because they want to understand what's
happening and like when big things happen
like last week so much happened right like
prime minister resign we had this big budget which
people like for example when the budget came out
like we arranged the emergency shoot date because
it's like we cannot put out like some sometimes
you put out videos like boom on the Moment Like
This what's happening now and sometimes it's
educational videos we had like an educational
video and it was like after something mad like
that has happened we just have to respond to that
thing that happened you know what I mean like
yeah it's like it's almost like a responsibility
because some people oh my God crazy storm going on
some people are relying on us for analysis and
like um but we don't need ultimately this is
not a news channel you know this is not BBC News
this isn't this is a channel about helping people
understand the whole big picture situation and
how we can improve that over the long term because
it has to be over the long term because we are
not going to win this in the short term but we
can win this in the long term and what is this
what is this that we're winning number one is
stopping the collapse in people's living standards
that's the number one and in my opinion the only
way to do that is to stop the massive increase
in inequality um and the way I envisage that
is it is going to come from people
insisting on it people demanding it
you know because before I did this I did a
lot of different things I went to University
change is not going to come from there and
I bounced around like think tanks and things
like that and there's good people in these think
tanks and stuff like that but ultimately these
think tanks they talk to the politicians and
the politicians say oh we're not going to give
you a wealth tax because people don't like it
people are not going to vote for it you know
so you know these Think Tank guys are richer
people the politicians are richer people
they're in their little space they're not
really getting hurt by it they're not going
to give you unless you demand it so for me what
I saw was nobody is talking to the people who
are actually being hurt by this you know what
I mean that was the thing that frustrated me
the most I think about the way that like the
whole conversation about economics hmm it's
like Rich professors Rich journalists Rich guys
on the TV rich people writing articles you know
and yet none of them are really making the
effort to turn around and talk to the people
that are getting hurt you know I'm very aware that
I am not getting personally hurt you know what I
mean yeah and but then would you say you're
not getting personally hurt on the basis of
what you've accumulated for yourself or because
of your lifestyle I mean I mean financially I
don't because I own assets you know what I
mean and you know I have wealth and I think
these are the people you know people with work
for people who've been protected you know yeah
um but like you're not an extra struggling person
on a personal level but I understand like you know
you and I both know what is happening you know
what I mean there's families that are literally
worried about feeding their kids here right and
you know you know I don't have to worry about
their own getting paid I don't have to worry about
the Bills game you know yeah the bills got to 10
grand and I could still pay them yeah it would be
expensive I could still pay them you know so I'm
just aware that there's people are being hurt like
viscerally and I'm not getting hit in that way
um but then it just drives me mad to see all of
these richer people having a discussion about it
oh we can't do it because people are not going
to vote for it who are you which of you is even
explaining to the people what's happening you know
what I mean so what what I really wanted like oh
before I started this YouTube I was writing
articles you know I wrote for the guardian I
wrote open democracy you know and it got picked up
by these kind of economy people and I don't know
these are a lot of these people are good people
they want to make positive change happen right
but I was very aware that you know people that I
grew up with I'm not reading those articles you
know what I'm eating yeah and I just felt like who
is talking to these people you know I mean like
if these people are going to get [__]
over at the very least they deserve to
have explained to them what's happening you
know what I mean but instead you just get
baffled by the stuff on the TV in the news so
um that's like for me ultimately at his heart
I think the thing what I believe with the thing
that gives me hope is I honestly believe if
people understood what was happening here
they would not accept it and we would get
changed if people knew the direction that we as
a society are heading and where we're going to go
70 80 90 of people would vote against it
and the only reason that we are able to
make Society worse and worse and worse and worse
and worse the way we are doing is because people
are misinformed and not giving good information
if people knew what is happening what was going
to happen they were not accept it so I feel like
this misinformation sorry yeah is that intentional
um there's a degree of intentional misinformation
so you know if you look for example at like Rupert
Murdoch's news Empire like they definitely want
to push don't tax the rich they'll leave they
definitely want to push that this is because of
immigrants this is because of foreigners you know
um and that is I think Kim protecting himself
and his class as a billionaire and you know if
you look at things like the iea which is a big
right-wing think tank that gets funded by rich
people and they put people on the news you know
like I saw a clip the other day of a lot of like
American news channels and they were all talking
about how amazing Liz trust's Economic Policy was
and when I saw that what that said to me was look
how much money is going into convincing you that
this is good like it's I think it's more obvious
in that American Media where like there's so much
aggressively right with media you know it's funded
by billionaires but to a later extent it happens
here you know who owns The Daily Mail billionaire
you know who owns a telegraph millionaire who owns
a times billionaire you know what I mean all
of these newspapers are owned by billionaires
you know so you know who owns Skype billionaire so
like and you know I speak to people in journalism
and they'll they'll tell you of course there's
a degree to which individual journalists get
freedom but ultimately there is an editorial line
that comes down from the top you know and I think
if when the money is coming from rich people it
influences the way people say it the way what
people say so I think there is a degree to which
it is intentional which is rich people pushing the
narrative but there is also a degree to which it
just comes down to the fact that the media is not
really designed to inform you it is designed to
entertain you this is something I've spoken about
some other videos which is like I've worked in
the city you know say what you like about the city
there are some liquids there and there are some
guys that are not that smart at the end of the day
these guys are [__] paid to be right and they're
trying to be right you know at least a lot of them
are you know what I mean and they can't just they
can't just chat [__] and they can't put [__]
trades on they have to try and be right because
if you look at the media you know I get called
to go on the news right I know what it's going to
be like it's just blah blah blah blah blah what
sounds good what looks good no like and I've I've
cut down on doing media because I started coming
away from them and thinking who was educated
what what did anybody really learn you know I
can go on LBC and have a fight with Nick Ferrari
you know what I mean but ultimately what do you
learn as a listener all we do is just we just put
poison into it you know what I mean what I want
to do is to educate ordinary working people all
the new people in ordinary Financial situations
that I think that ultimately of course only that
is going to lead us to a positive outcome so when
we talk about educating and backtracking ever so
slightly towards the start of the conversation
so a couple things you're saying that you want
people to to demand the change yeah who are they
demanding it from I know you did talk about the
think tanks and politicians and certain things
going into place who are they actually demanding
it from how feasible are these demands yeah and
if they're making these demands yeah then you know
there has to be some give elsewhere whether that
affects you know the super wealthy or whatnot
whether they they notice that that difference
like it's obviously going to have to give
somewhere else and will it effectively mean
that it could affect you know other services
that are available would they kind of take from
them like they have been or or they currently
do I don't think they're going to turn around
and take for you because you made demands um I
think you know we do still live in a democracy
right and I think what you see I think brexit
is a good example right when brexit came around
when they're when the referendum came around
both the two major parties you know we live in
a two-part system we're very anti-brexit and they
push they lost the referendum and they were still
anti-brexit but eventually people demand enough
people demanded it and enough people ultimately
said we're only going to vote based on brexit
that both parties essentially had to come around
um I think that tax in the rich will be a harder
fight than brexit because I think a lot of rich
people don't really care that much about brexit
because they didn't really hit them um whereas
tax in the rich they'll be bigger pushback um but
I think voting is important you know what I mean
and I know a lot of people don't like to hear that
but it is important and it's it's not even about
I spoke about this bit in the last video it's not
even about conservatives or labor it's about being
it's a you know these guys are always doing
polling they're always asking people what do
you want what do you want what do you want I want
these guys to do a poll group and have everybody
say to them I don't give a [__] unless you fix
what's inequality I want this to be the message
coming out the polling groups and that comes I
think actually people have a lot more power than
they actually think and not as individuals but
as the the conversation that we have as a group
you know if everybody turns around and says
[__] these guys we want brexit then they'll
get it and if everybody turns around and says
listen these guys are just a bunch of crooks
they're not doing anything unless they fix wealth
inequality with [__] and if that is the message
coming out from you know I want people phoning
into LBC saying that I tell you this is a good
story right and I can't mention any names right
but recently I've been getting contacted by a lot
of politicians right and I was in a room with
politicians okay and a conservative politician
puts her hand up and says that money that 450
billion pounds given that in covert who's got
it now well and there was people in that room
looking at turning and looking at me because
they know I've been pushing that line they are
from day after day after day and it's just a
realization that she's just met or that person
this politician didn't hear it from me but she
heard it from someone and ultimately that person
would heard it from someone who would have heard
it from someone who probably would have heard it
from me and that is because of the conversation
that we have as a group like this is not I run a
YouTube channel and everybody comes to me this is
I run a YouTube channel and you start asking
this question to your mates and people start
calling into LBC and people start posting on their
Twitter people start posting on their Facebook
like ultimately the conversation that we have as
a society has the power to push these politicians
you know and if enough if it becomes generally
accepted that listen the only way we're going to
fix this is wealth inequality the politicians will
have to do it and don't get me wrong it will be
a fight but the thing is at the moment we are not
there yet but it's like that you know you get the
message out I tell you you tell your mates you
know your mates come and watch this Channel and
then they start they people start using their
own media channels you know what I mean it's
it's an echo chamber and it's like everybody
has a voice and it's like okay not everybody has
a YouTube channel but you you have your mates at
football your mate to the pub you have your family
you know what I mean you have the people at work
you can influence this conversation you know what
I mean and you know I would encourage people put
the phone in to talk radio and LBC and whatever
whatever the news programs are phone in get it
out put it on your Twitter put it on your Facebook
tell your mates tell your friends or your family
and then eventually I here get politicians coming
back to me quoting the lines what I am saying
but they didn't hear it from me it's because
it's because we are a community and
we are a society and and you know
you have a power to influence the beliefs
of the people in your life you know what I
mean yeah and it's you you share it and
I share and then eventually it becomes
it becomes common sense and the politicians have
to do it you know and but don't get me wrong we
will get pushback and you know we're not at that
stage here because we're not at that level yet you
know there are still people who disagree with
these ideas but we need to get it you know not
just me but you and the people who are watching
you know and I will do as much as I can but it
will only work you know it's not going to work
because everyone in the country subscribes to my
YouTube channel you know what I mean it's going
to work because enough people subscribe to my
YouTube channel and they tell their friends and
then they tell and they tell their friends and
you know everybody shares the voice you know it's
that's that's how it works you know I did spread
for a community it's not like it's not one person
it's a it's a is a combination of many one people
working together you know is is your plants kind
of like address this globally because inequality
exists everywhere and anywhere I would love
for it to be Global and you know I do as and
where I can try and build up International links
it's very important for people to realize that
this problem is not a UK only problem this
is happening everywhere um I'm aware that
I my voice is much louder in the UK than
it is around the world and also like
you know people are just more amenable to a
mess like I understand what's happening here
you know and people hear me and they know this
guy is from here you know what I mean yeah you
know I get people from all over the country
I think a big thing is like in the UK there's
not a lot of like regular working-class voices
especially talking about economics on TV on the
radio so like you don't need to be from London I
get messages from people from Scotland or people
from the northwest or people from Wales or people
from the Midlands all over saying like you know
they watch the video in ilford and they're
like I grew up just like you you know what I
mean so I know that like in the reality like
I have a lot more power to make a voice hit
and that is what I'm focusing on but you know
when the book comes out it's going to come out
in America and it's going to kind of come out
all over the world you know what I mean and
if you look at the like the one big time in
history when we did achieve a big decrease
in inequality which is after the second world war
it was very much an international thing okay and
um I think that success will be a lot easier
if we can have people saying that these kind
of things you know like I say we're a
community in the end of the day you know
we're not just a national Community these things
are happening everywhere you know and if you have
if you do have connections in other countries talk
to them and they will tell you you know you know
there are countries that have a lot worse
inequality than here and there are countries that
have less than here but inequality is increasing
everywhere and the same problems can't afford
housing can't get a decent job you know worried
about being able to have a family these things
happening everywhere so do these things cycle
so does it get worse and then get a little bit
better and then get worse um yeah they do but you
know if we use like history as a guide you know
things got really bad before they got better
you know the last you know you know we had the
first world war and that didn't really fix things
things got worse after that and you know you know
you don't need me to tell you what happened after
the first world war you know I mean we had whole
countries brought into fascism we had the Nazis
we had the Holocaust where the Second World War
and you know only then after that did we get a
reduction in equality and a good sign of living so
yes things cycle but things cycle because we make
it happen you know I mean it's not like a natural
thing it's not like the sun goes down the sun
will come up there's some will only come up if
we make no one is going to turn around and give
us this this increase in living standards and it's
decreasing inequality that is only going to come
from us fighting for it and us making it happen
yeah but I guess it kind of goes back to
where do you kind of Target your fight
who who am I to fight like if I haven't
even got enough time or money to get on
with my day-to-day why am I going to waste
time in this fight that is not necessarily
gonna happen and then that's me exerting my time
wasting my time wasting my energy trying to fight
don't get me wrong I fully understand what you're
saying there has to be someone out there to make
a change it takes people to make this change
yeah but I just feel there's a lot of people
that will just be like and I'm not talking
for anyone in particular I maybe maybe have
it in my mindset where I'm kind of like you
know I've just got to do what I've got to
do you know I I do what I do and then I go to
sleep yeah like anything that can can happen
within that is a bonus but yeah realistically
how much time and effort can I put into this
but what do I need to put into this the way I
see it and the way I approach it myself for me
I see it as I take what I need and I give what
I can and like I'm 100 aware I'm in a situation
where it is much much easier for me to give a lot
than it is for a lot of people you know I've been
doing this work unpaid for years of course not
hardly anyone can do that you know what I mean
yeah um and not only that you know I've got this
background of studying this stuff for years I'm
not going to expect you to turn around and be an
expert on this stuff and make a website about it
you know what I mean yeah um and I'm also aware
that there is this problem of first of all like
this YouTube is open to everyone but really
who is fought in my mind is the people who
see the economics on the news and think what the
[__] are you talking about I don't understand
we're talking about and and people who are worried
it's the people who are getting hurt and not being
spoken to you know because I feel they need to be
a space for just ordinary people you know what I
mean um and I'm aware that increasingly people in
the average financial situation is increasingly a
struggle so I'm aware that people I'm speaking
to very often you know don't have a lot to give
and you know I'm not asking for money I wouldn't
expect money but often they also don't have time
and energy because they're just struggling to take
up their families in this and I would never turn
around to anyone I would never turn around to
you and say bro you need to help me with this
you know what I mean like you're here today you
know because you have a bit of time to come right
but we're never talking about if you if you say to
me like I can't because I'm working I can't I've
got to do this for my for my family I would never
say you have to um I would leave you totally like
in the power and the decision of the people who
watch but I know I know like from the I've seen it
that the people who have little are
still in many cases willing and they
want to help you know I went up to Richardson's
constituency in North Yorkshire to a food bank
um so I feel like to speak to people about like
do you know how rich vicious and the cost of
living crisis and just coincidentally
it happened to be immediately after
the invasion of Ukraine so I'm going up this food
bank in North Yorkshire right and it's you know
oh everyone in there just packing stuff
everyone is in volunteers packing stuff
and then four guys are gonna drive put it in
lorries they're lorries and drive to Ukraine
and um I asked the people like who are these
people here and it was the food bank users
so these are the people that don't even have
enough to eat and yet you see this thing happen
like a thousand miles away and you are going
to go and do that and I think that is like
I've seen that in my life like I know that
people don't much but they are willing and
I wouldn't ask anyone to give more than
they can give yeah it's just like it's
just like if all you can do is watch the
videos and understand as best you can just
do that and even if you can't watch
other videos don't do that but like
just tell your friends to your family look try
to understand what's happening just say listen
there's a guy I think he knows what he's talking
about he says the only way to fix this is to fix
wealth inequality you know it seems like he
knows his stuff check him out you know he
just and then it's what can you and like there
will be things that you can do that I didn't
even think about people ask me what can I
do what can I do the truth is I do I make
a YouTube channel I'm talking about economics
because I know economics you know what I mean
yeah but as an ordinary person you know I'm not
you know I've lived in Japan and I've lived in
Oxford and I've been all over right I'm not
really as connected to the local community
but there will be a lot of people who what they
just have is you know there will be guys around
here watch my videos and then they just got
the Masjid you know what I mean tell the guys
at mustard you know I mean I don't know those
guys you tell it you know what I mean like it's
and there'll be people who like you know there'll
be people who are created you know what I mean who
who know who can make other ways of communicating
these ideas I think what it is about is
you don't need to do anything you know what I
mean and I would never demand it from anyone but
look at your situation and say what can I do and
it's if it's just something that's like you know
you know if everybody tells one other person
then you get everyone that's what it takes
you know what I mean just try and understand
it and try and communicate these ideas with
with the people around you and just get
into the conversation it's like that's
that's who I would ask and you know I get messages
so many messages for people I want to help I want
to help and I find it difficult because I can't
I would love to reply to all of them yeah like
just it's enough to just spread the message he
said it's enough to understand it to recognize
that it is good and that is important and to
spread it like that is ultimately if everybody
supports it what happened so really all you need
to do is to support it you know and if you can do
more fantastic but like and if you're in a space
where literally you are struggling to pay the
bills then do that you know what I mean I wouldn't
ask for anything more it's a question of like
how much time and energy do you have and I know
because I've seen it that people are struggling
still want to help I've seen it enough times
yeah definitely oh that sky looks amazing
money currently is Flowing from the
government to the rich leaving the
government with big powers of debt and the
rich would be part of money there's one other
thing they can do with that mass amount
of income they can buy your mom's house
[Music]